so I'm Noah this is joint work with a
dad Daniel and divest you'll hear from
Daniel a little bit when he talks about
a nice extension of this algorithm and
i'll be showing you the state of the art
in salt and finding shortest vectors so
before we start I should just give a
disclaimer that this is not the fastest
algorithm to break crypto this is the
fastest algorithm for the exact a
variant of this problem for the
approximate versions we have slightly
faster prop algorithm so I just sort of
want to make that disclaimer I'm not I'm
not claiming anything that's not true
and this algorithm is very very simple
so please interrupt me if you're not
understanding because you should be
understanding so with that let's define
a lattice I think you guys all know this
it's a discrete set of vectors in RN
here's one in two dimensions looks like
that and it's specified by a basis so
here's a basis for this lattice their
set of linearly independent vectors and
the lattice itself is a set of integer
linear combination as the basis vectors
I think we've all seen this before the
shortest vector problem just ask us to
find the shortest nonzero vector the
lattice right so the shortest vector in
the lattice is zero that's boring the
shortest nonzero vector the lattice is
very interesting so here's it in this
lattice I think this is known to be
np-hard even to approximate which is why
i'm going to show you an exponential
time algorithm and just some notation we
write lambda one of the latticed
represent the length of the shortest
factor and I'm always talking about
Euclidean norm so for this lattice this
is lambda 1 so this problems received a
lot of study it's quite important works
was sort of initiated by Kanaan and 86
with an enumeration based algorithm that
I ran in n to the end time but
interestingly in poly n space which
still makes it interesting today and
then a breakthrough work in 2001 aight
aight kumar and shiva kumar show
deceiving algorithm that ran in singly
exponential time which was a big open
problem for a while as you can see and a
lot of work was done to bring down the
constant the exponent this is a small
subset of the works on this I think the
current best with the sieving approach
is to the 2.5 roughly
then and then in another breakthrough
result in 2010 Machado and vulgaris
showed a deterministic singly
exponential sorry distinct exponential
time algorithm based on the Voronoi cell
for both SVP and CVP so remember Daniels
going to show you our CVP algorithm so
this algorithm was interesting both
because it's deterministic and because
it's helped CDP and because it brought
the constant the exponent down now 22 so
this is a 4 to the n time algorithm in
this work I'm going to improve things by
a quadratic factor so I'll show you a 2
to the N time algorithm and for what
it's worth it's randomized so the
fastest or mystic algorithm is still
Daniela's so that's the history here's
our algorithm so my primary tool is a
discrete Gaussian distribution so first
I'll give you some intuition based on
the continuous Gaussian distribution so
this is how a notated continuous
Gaussian distribution assigns to a
vector X probability proportional to its
Gaussian wait e to the minus length of x
squared divided by s squared so s you
can think of as the standard deviation
up to some constant factor it's just
scaling factor and all I want you to
know about this distribution for now so
it looks like this roughly and when I
lower the parameter it gets narrower
that's all I want you to know so lower
standard deviation narrower Gaussian so
for a discrete Gaussian distribution we
simply assigned wait proportional to the
Gaussian mass of a lattice vector now so
now why is the lattice vector that's why
it's red and we're just going to take
the distribution of the signs Gaussian
Gaussian weight to each vector so for
fairly high parameters and two
dimensions it looks like this it just
sort of looks like a pixelated Gaussian
distribution and but if we lower the
parameter of course as you might expect
it gets narrower if we zoom in a bit we
can see the sort of lower resolution now
sort of the set that supported on is now
in some sense sparser if we keep going
it sort of stopped looks less and less
Gaussian if I go even further then
things get sort of silly now it's sort
of only supported on really nine vectors
and if I go further than that something
is just get ridiculous than my
I'm just sampling zero but I want you to
pay attention to this parameter so
things are rather misleading in two
dimensions but the thing to notice here
is that this is a shortest factor so if
i were to sample from this distribution
on this two dimensional lattice that
would get a shorter specter with fairly
high probability we're trying to solve
the show respect your problem so this is
good for us of course in higher
dimensions things might be a little
messy but the intuition that we can take
from this is that if we get enough
samples where I'll define enough in a
second from the right parameter I'll
define not in a second too but it's
rather small then we can sample from the
short then we can solve the shortest
vector problem in particular if you use
a rather heavy hammer so I certainly
won't show you this proof you can show
that we need about a 1.38 to the n
vectors with s about lambda 1 over
square root n so polynomial factors
won't matter to us much here so
basically you want a sample from
parameter portion to the shortest vector
and this uses the the kissing number
bound of a cop a chance can leverage 9
now for very high parameters the
discrete Gaussian is extremely well
studied in particular above the
so-called smoothing parameter which I
want to find formally but intuitively
it's when when it looks like a Gaussian
so at the beginning I showed you a sort
of very nice pixelated Gaussian
distribution that was above the
smoothing parameter by the time I got to
these sort of weird distributions no
longer smooth and in particular Gentry
pi Kurt and Viking Jonathan who were all
here showed how to sample in this regime
in polynomial time so above smoothing at
least well above smoothing we know we
know how to sample from this
distribution but previously even in
exponential time there was no algorithm
the sample below smoothing short is
vector should be so we can guess it I
mean also we're going to go down in sort
of increments so we could just sort of
take the shortest factor that we happen
to find but yeah we can just guess it up
to like some small factor but good
question yeah so just to hammer this
home this nice smooth pretty
distribution is easy to sample from this
weird distribution is hard to sample
from
because it has a much lower parameter
and there's a natural question which is
can we use samples from the right hand
side or your left hand side to get
samples from your right hand side so
this is going to be our goal right so
we'll call this converting Gaussian
vectors by which I mean sort of lowering
the parameter we're going to do this
sort of incrementally and again we'll
take our intuition from the continuous
Gaussian distribution so if I sort of
give you Oracle access to a continuous
Gaussian distribution and I want you to
output another continuous Gaussian with
the parameter lowered by some factor
what would you do there's extremely
simple answer do you have a question ok
there's an extremely simple answer which
is 2/2 right so it's a very simple
property that's free calcium that if i
divide by 2 I get another Gaussian with
smaller parameter so we can ask if this
works in the in the lattice case right
so here's the discrete Gaussian kind of
divided by 2 and get another discrete
calcium with the lower parameter so the
answer is of course no and the reason is
quite simple let's say I sampled this
vector and then I take half of it half
of its not even in the lattice right so
this this fails rather tremendously so
that's not going to work but we can
imagine getting around this by
conditioning on the result being in the
lattice so it turns out that if we do
that we get the right distribution this
is just a formal statement saying that
we get the right distribution right so
probability that y over 2 equals some
vector X conditioned on it being in the
lattice is proportional to the Gaussian
mass but now we have this nice factor
for in the exponent which is progress
that means that we've lowered the
parameter by by a factor of 2 when
unfortunately this requires us to throw
out a lot of vectors and even were above
smoothing this requires us to throw out
about to only keep like one and every 2
to the n vectors we want to do this a
few times super constant of x so this
isn't going to work for us but now we
can consider another way of converting
Gaussian vectors we can consider I'm
just gonna sort of tell you this cuz I
don't know how natural it is taking
their average all right so you take the
average of two gaussian vectors the
result is again a Gaussian with the
parameter lowered now by a factor of
square root 2
so we can ask the same question about
the discrete Gaussian if I take their
average is the result another discrete
Gaussian with the parameter lowered and
the answer is again no right so take two
vectors take their average not in the
lattice same problem so it seems like we
haven't gotten anywhere but I'm giving
you this talk because we did get
somewhere so we can ask what about
conditioning on the vectors landing in
the lattice and now i'm going to give
you a sort of proof by picture so the
question is if i have two vectors sample
from the discrete calcium with the same
parameter and i take their average and I
condition on the result being the
lattice what do I get and here's my
proof by picture so Oh before the proof
I picture sorry let's ask just when we
have y1 the average being in the lattice
so I have two lattice vectors i can
write them in terms of the basis that's
the definition so these are integer
coordinates and i can write their
average in terms of the basis when is
the average in the lattice so when these
are integers so when are these averages
all integers it's just exactly when all
the coefficients have parity the
corresponding coefficients have the same
parity right another way to say this is
that y 1 is equivalent to y 2 modular
twice the lattice this is just sort of
algebraic way of saying this so just to
hammer this home we have that the
average of two last vectors is in the
lattice if and only if they line the
same cosset mod twice the lattice and
there are 2 to the N cosets one for each
parody vector mod n so this is like one
of the most technical parts of our
algorithm I swear so we can imagine
instead of when we sample a pair of
lattice vectors we can think of this as
sampling from the product lattice so L
times L this is just the gaussians
invariant under taking products is still
a Gaussian so here's Elle cross L in two
dimensions because that's the best I can
do or rather in one dimension because
that's the best I can do and then one
dimension there's only two kinds of
parody there's even an there's odd so
we're interested in vectors whose
coordinates have the same parity so here
are the vectors whose coordinates are
all odd here the vectors whose
coordinates are all even we're going to
throw out the rest so this is sort
of what we get after we condition and
you can note that this is also allowed
us I'll call it L bagger so it's just a
set of points y1 and y2 that have the
same parity and here's my proof by
picture it turns out that you're looking
at this in the wrong way you should be
tilting your head sideways so I'll do it
for you if you tell your head about 45
degrees or I rotated about 45 degrees or
exactly 45 degrees rather you see that
what you get actually after this
rotation is a product lattice so this is
actually L times L scaled up by a factor
square root 2 this is what makes our
algorithm work this is merely the whole
proof so why is this helpful so this
means that if I sample y1 and y2 from
this L dagger yeah no no I'm showing you
that this conditional distribution is
right and I'm going to show you how to
sample from it so if i take y1 and y2
from l dagger discrete gaussian over l
dagger and i rotate it this means i get
to discrete gaussian over this product
lattice this is just saying the discrete
gaussian is invariant under rotation
gaussian measures in a variant
interpretation now I just write down
what this rotation is this is the
rotation that I just showed you it's the
first coordinate is y1 plus y2 over
square root 2 in the second coordinate
is that thing to notice is that the
first coordinate looks a lot like an
average is just scaled wrong so in
particular if I instead took the average
and I threw in that second coordinate
which won't be important to us that's
the same as rotating and dividing by a
square root 2 which means that if we
take the average than the first
coordinate will be distributed as a
descrição seen on L with the parameter
drop by a factor of square root 2 so
that shows that this conditional
distribution if we take the average of
two lattice vectors condition on the
result being in the lattice the result
is yeah so the square root 2 is a
progress and if we condition on the
result being the last we take the
average of two lattice vectors the
result is again a discreet Gaussian with
the parameter drop by a factor square
too so we're now left with a question of
how do we sample from this conditional
distribution so let's just sort of write
down the probability that we get the
probability that the average to last
vector is equals some value conditioned
on them landing in the lattice well so
this lands a lot it's exactly one there
in the same cosset mod to L so this
probability the probability that y 1 is
in a given co set is actually going to
be proportional to the weight of the
cosets squared it's essentially
collision right so this is going to be
the sum over Co SEPs of the probability
that a discrete Gaussian vector lands in
the cosets squared times the discrete
Gaussian sort of over the coset but the
important thing to note is that this
weight of this the cosets is squared
here so this suggests an algorithm and
this is almost exactly what we do our
input will be roughly two to the n
samples from dls think sort of
asymptotically a bit larger than two to
the N we're then going to separate the
vectors into buckets according to their
co set so we expect as long as the
cosets have roughly even way we expect
to have some some vectors in each co set
each bucket and then we're simply going
to pair a number of vectors from each
cosset proportional to the size of the
coset squared the number of vectors that
we got into co steps squared so this
squared corresponds to that squared and
then we're going to output the averages
of the pairs so this pairing is what
gives us this yeah mod too well oh my
two of the vectors why so I have a bunch
of vectors why that I sample it from the
discrete Gaussian I can look at their co
set mod 2 l.i can group them by those
concepts and then if I take the average
of two vectors in the same co set that
will land in the lattice right and i
know that if i take this conditional
distribution so I condition on them
landing and in the same co set then I
get a descrição seal with the parameter
lowered this is just a trick to sample
from the conditional distribution much
more quickly than you get otherwise it's
sort of amortized cost to the damn yeah
so before you had the Sun and the
fans of this directors disappear you
only have the Sun we could take the
difference to it's just so what do you
draw the difference at all oh well I
think the only no way that I know how to
give this proof by picture is working in
2 n dimensions instead of n dimensions
so you get this you get this extra
difference yeah yeah I can win a factor
of two yeah but I'm hiding things that
cost us like a polynomial factor so the
factor 2 is not going to be important to
us yep yeah so well also know so we
sampled originally so this is and it
turns out that the way that we really do
step two is random because we're
actually going to do this
probabilistically so we get an exact
thing not in a nun approximate so so I'm
going I'm just so now I'm just saying
there's some proportionality constant I
have this list of numbers and I'm going
to a for each bucket I'm going to take a
number of pairs that's proportional to
this size now I'll tell you the
proportionality constant exactly now hmm
step one is a very big eight of you like
like the song step two is is the is
something good going on yeah um when
added together so it's sort of castles
of the joint but he's doing it for you
yeah i mean this this is similar to like
a lot I mean similar to seething
algorithms in some way as well like I
think I think what's new here is that we
really decide to control the
distribution so our output is scouting
and we figured out that this this is a
way to do it with fruit by picture so I
have the number of vectors that I output
is going to be some proportionality
constant T times the sum of the size of
the co steps square right so what
proportionality constant T can I take
well I want to take the largest one
possible and the largest thing that I
can take is one over the size of the
maximal cosset if I take anything larger
than that then I'd have to help put more
vectors than I have that's no good I'm
leaving out a factor of two here because
I'm taking pairs but we don't care about
factors of 2 but we know the
distribution of these vectors so we know
roughly what this will be if we start
out with em input vectors then this will
be roughly M times the sum of the
probability that we on this Coast F
squared divided by the maximum
probability of a cosa this is a
collision probability / a maximum
probability and I think cryptographers
are fairly used to seeing things like
this is you can think of this as rennie
entropy compared to men entropy so we
know that actually this can be quite bad
so the worst-case ratio here is actually
2 to the N over 2 so I can lose my sort
of loss factor can be to the n over two
hear after a single step which seems
really bad remember that when we had a
loss factor to the end before we decide
we threw that algorithm out immediately
so now we have 2 to the N over 2 we
saved a factor too but that that doesn't
seem quite enough so now we panic but
I'm talking to you so something works
out here and this is really really
magical this is this is the most
technical part of the talk I think I
said that earlier it was false so oh
yeah no this is the most technical part
of the talk I swear Daniels will be more
technical so I have this collision
probability / this maximum probability
and I just want you to note that this
collision probability we actually gave
this a name earlier right so we have the
sort of collision lattice this L dagger
that I name dry there so this is just
the
gaussian massive l dagger / the Gaussian
mass of the product lattice was just the
mass of the lattice squared um but I
also have a very nice identity on l
dagger I know that the Gaussian massive
L dagger is the Gaussian mass of this
scale dot product lattice and now I'm
just going to rewrite this this is the
same as the Gaussian massive lattice
squared with a factor square root you
now in the parameter so I've now
simplified well arguably simplified the
numerator the denominator it turns out
i'm just going to tell you this if
you've seen lattices this freak out you
know all you know this but if you
haven't just take my word for it it
turns out that the central code set has
the maximum mass so the central code set
is too well so particular the
probability of the central cosset is the
weight of 2l divided by the weight of
the whole lattice so the weight of the
whole lattice cancels out and this is
the final expression that we get
although just to write it slightly
differently I want to take that too and
put it in the parameter so this is our
loss factor and again this can be as bad
as to the N over 2 but now I'm going to
consider the loss factor over many
applications so I'm going to run this
algorithm many times and these
parameters here this is just saying that
my parameter goes down by a factor of
square root 2 every time so remember
that i'm going to apply this many many
times and each time my parameter goes
down by a factor square root 2 so this
is the loss factor that i get from
running this l times i guess but note
that this is a telescoping product so in
fact almost everything cancels and
you're left with just a ratio from the
beginning and a ratio from the end
everything else cancels out that might
be slightly too complicated for you to
see right now but I promise I didn't lie
and this last factor here this is
actually greater than or equal to 1 in
reality it's basically one for our
purposes but this is greater than equal
to 1 so what matters is this factor here
and this is a fairly standard bound
proven originally by Banaszak you can
see this intuitively just by pretending
that this is a continuous Gaussian if
this were a continuous Gaussian this
were an integral instead of a sum then
the factor that you get here would be to
the minus n over 2 and it turns out that
lattices are bounded by that so in fact
this loss factor is no worse than to the
minus n over 2 so I started out by
telling you that the loss factor in one
step can be 2 to the N over 2 I'm now
telling you that the loss factor in L
steps is also in most to the N over 2 so
somehow we have this magical property
that no matter how long i run this the
loss factor is never worse than the
worst case loss factor in a single step
which we don't understand we have no
geometric interpretation of this proof
the proof is really quick we don't
understand why it's true though so if I
start out to the end vectors which I
need to start out with at the end I'll
get to the n over two vectors this is
multiplication and remember something I
told you earlier that you probably
forgot we only need one point three
eight to the n samples to solve sv p to
the n over 2 greater than 1.38 to the N
so as if by magic we've solved the
problem so that was probably a little
fast let me show you the final algorithm
it's fairly simple so here's RSVP solver
we're going to first use gpp to get
about 2 to the n samples from the
discrete gaussian with some fairly high
parameter significantly bigger than
lambda 1 we're then going to repeatedly
run this sort of squaring combining
process on the result so we're going to
group everything by buckets we're going
to take values proportional we're going
to take from each bucket and a number of
vectors proportional to the square of
the size and we're going to take
averages of the resulting vectors and
then if we do this the right number of
times and again we can guess the right
number of times then we're just then we
get to output 2 to the N over 2 samples
from dls with the parameter now much
lower so the proof that I just showed
you shows that this is actually what we
get that we get to the N over 2 samples
and that the parameter has dropped as we
want to drop no well okay the way I
showed it to you yes but we use a thing
called the Poisson trick I don't know if
you've heard of it but it's a way to get
it to take a multinomial distribution
and convert it into a bunch of
independent Bernoulli distributions so
we have a multinomial distribution over
the code sets and then we get a bunch of
independent
bernoulli distributions over the coset
so we have no independence issues at all
there's a small error that we get from
that but it's like 2 to the minus N
squared if you want so it doesn't matter
and then because of the fact that that
we know we only need one point three
eight to the n vectors to get a shorter
Specter that means that if we just
output the shortest nonzero vector from
our samples with overwhelming
probability will get a shorter Specter
that's the full algorithm so this is me
they even start from less than 2 to the
n vectors ya know so in order to do my
bucketing when I'm above smoothing I
actually need to the end I mean even
like polynomial a more than 2 to the N
yeah so we're running times really to to
the end and I don't see an easy way
around that so no funny you should get
all the way from something huge to what
you want well I have this like I the
factor goes down by square root 2 each
time so yeah I'm doing it iteratively
I'm doing repeatedly yeah I do it I do
it over and over and over again yeah
exactly so like I have them samples to
combines of something that gets whole
number sense that you try to combine
them again yeah yeah yeah so there's
there's there's something that I was
hoping to gloss over but somehow
magically it works out that if you look
at the loss factor after I steps we end
up getting exactly the number of vectors
that we need to fill the buckets in the
ice step so some buckets are going to be
totally insignificant because they have
really low probability and and it works
out for again reasons that we really
don't understand so well that we always
have the right number of vectors that if
it is like you symbolisms and you group
if you get this letter since this is
what I'm a double of what I was a you
you pretend it's also your new samples
and you again yeah I take the average
and then I pretend they're my new
samples yeah then you go up do it again
so yeah yeah and you're saying is entha
you do it enough steps you still have to
resign over to sample so in one step you
might have to resign over to them yeah
yeah I mean I'm hiding loss additional
loss factor so we can't really run it
forever but but yeah essentially
so again just to start out i need to to
the end yeah yeah so i'll tell you in a
second that we have a kind of way around
this ish but it's not what you're
thinking yeah so we had this algorithm
at some point but it turns out it's
simpler just to start out with a pretty
good basis so at the beginning we start
out with a pretty good basis that our
samples aren't that far above lambda 1
to begin with actually so so in this
probability analysis you were paying
attention to the square of the bucket
side then don't just end up taking all
possible combinations so you exactly no
no no I fried a lot of vectors in fact I
can throw out like a 2 to the N over 2
fraction of the vectors in one run I
throw out a lot of vectors you actually
do the sampling according to that I
distribution then you can stay i think
that like that's the big difference like
if you want to view this is a seething
algorithm which some people do then
that's the big difference we know are
approaching the other approach we care
about the distribution so we just throw
out vectors to get the right
distribution we also don't pay attention
to the length of the vectors at all I
never mentioned the length of a vector
in the algorithm maybe just say again
what's this policy for when you throw a
lot of the better when you actually so I
mean the rough idea is that I want to
output a number of vectors before smell
to the square of the size right so let's
say there are two buckets that came from
the fact that this conditional
probability is like a collision
probability so it assigns weight squared
each co set and I know that this
collision prob this conditional
probability is exactly what I want by
that sort of rotation proof
again you have today in samples in the
first step in the arrow yeah you still
need to the end samples and say yeah so
that's the answers that I really don't
um yeah so I only only lose if if the
vectors aren't rough if the buckets are
in roughly uniform and if they're not
roughly uniform then in the next step
the sort of ones that were far off from
uniform are going to be totally
insignificant so it turns out that sort
of like exactly the number of the number
of vectors that I lose or the number
vectors that i'm left with is exactly
what i need to fill up the remaining
sort of significant buckets yeah I think
yeah I mean the reason for the
telescoping product is a mystery to me
but yeah it follows from the same
algebra yeah so the number of samples
you really need is not to the end its to
the end it's 1 over it's 1 over the
probability of the maximal bucket so
basically i need enough samples to make
sure that the maximal bucket will at
least have some weight that's all yeah
so like if their uniform that i need to
to the end though they're not uniform
then I couldn't eat much less than that
so this gap between one point 78 and one
point whatever 44 this is a coincidence
like yeah there's no reason why that's
true i mean the kissing number bound
like i don't think people think it's
tight it's just what we can prove yeah i
don't think i don't think there's
something deep going on there it's
rather convenient for us got like
optimize it don't get something but we
don't know how yeah i mean it would save
us like you know 0.3 in the exponent or
something that but yeah we don't know
how far servation argues effects a
trade-off between running time and
qualitative our solution just run
vectors okay it doesn't matter how long
we run it though we're going to run it
like poly log n times we don't so we run
it we run it so little that so the loss
factor from the things that I showed you
is bounded and then the loss factor from
things I didn't show you is going to be
like to to the poly log n which we don't
care about so yeah I mean I guess you
could save like in the little event in
the exponent but other than that yeah
but i will show you something that does
do that like right now almost so i
showed you in this talk to to the end
time algorithm for SVP i actually showed
you something slightly better which is a
2 to the n time algorithm for discrete
casting sampling for any parameter s
that actually gives you to the n over 2
vectors this sort of an amortized
algorithm but just to hammer this point
home we don't get one vector in time 2
to the N over 2 we get to Dan over to
vectors into to the end time but there
is an additional result from this work
which uses the same idea but is
significantly more complicated which
gives us a 2 to the N over 2 time
algorithm that actually samples to the n
over two vectors also so it basically
loses nothing but except for little
event factors um but it only works above
the smoothing parameter although usually
when people say about the smoothing
parameter you mean like root n times the
smoothing parameter we mean actually
square root 2 times the smoothing
parameter so this buys us a lot it gives
us um a two approximation to the
decisional variant of gap SVP like you
were saying it also lets us solve b.ed
to pretty damn close to the unique
covering radius and it gives us rude n
log n s IV p we can probably do better
than that and the reach an additional
result is that i actually showed the
other direction there's just a preprint
right now but actually this recast and
sampling reduces the shortest vector
problem which I found to be very
surprising this is not an equivalent
because the other direction yeah okay
this is not an equivalent because the
other direction is an exponential time I
actually don't think that these problems
are equivalent I suspect that decreased
Gaussian sampling is not empty hard fact
that's one of my open questions and
because I'm a little overtime I'll just
sort of show these and i'll talk about
them
so thank you very much and here's a
short vector Daniel's going take a
second to set up so if you have any more
questions so one comment one of the
reason previous work it was something
about the smoothing parameter wrap it
was not just because people didn't know
how to sign by July so there was another
reason which was the primary well
actually no no sorry I disagree k swiss
ave but ya know i mean i agree that
nobody nobody saw a need to go below
smoothing parameter but I all's but
everything prior also incurred error
that depended on yeah what other family
reason people will look in a different
disagree agree agree yeah I think that
some other average result maybe have
some other abuse from where is not
uniform out of this I'm not sure my
guess would be no because like I don't
see a polynomial time reduction coming
out of this yeah